ciao ragazzi allora volevo fare questa
parte di video prima della recensione
perché volevo dirvi un paio di cose
velocemente
allora prima di tutto grazie mille per i
40.000 iscritti adesso siete veramente
tanti sì anzi siete molto oltre 40.000
iscritti e io non so veramente come
ringraziarvi sono strafelice che i miei
video vi piacciono ancora
solo al campo stranito ma sono anche
molto contento e quindi
non so come ringraziarvi ma cercherò di
fare qualcosa quindi restate
sintonizzati che qualcosa mi invento e
poi volevo dire un'altra cosa domenico
marotta
il creatore di web celebrity punto it ha
scritto un articolo su di me e su victor
l'asl 88 riguardo la nostra recensione
di inception fatto insieme che vi
ricordo se non l'avete ancora vista
andate sul canale di victor laslo e
cercate la perché credo che sia venuta
abbastanza bene per quanto sia difficile
recensire un film come inception e
quindi volevo ringraziare domenico per
le belle parole spese per l'articolo e
se volete
leggere l'articolo
vi linko il link nella descrizione del
video e volevo ringraziarlo perché io mi
sono stupito perché per le belle parole
anche perché nell'articolo oltre me
victor l'asl è citato anche
bestmovie.it che sono sicuro che voi lo
conoscerete qui il sito di cinema
stupendo uno dei migliori circolazioni
perché sicuramente quando cercate
qualche film sicuramente finirete su
quel sito di sicuro e anche quella
rivista che ogni tanto danno al cinema
best movie e io sono onorato di essere
un articolo insieme appunto al best
movie e se non lo conoscete vi linko
mass movie e o quante ripetizioni b
movie nell'inferno nell'informazione del
video e quindi volevo solo dirvi questo
un po alla veloce vi ringrazio
infinitamente degli iscritti e di tutti
i complimenti di tutti commenti che mi
lasciate sono veramente a centinaio
ormai non lo nego e io sono
contentissimo quindi è ancora grazie a
domenico marotta per l'articolo ripeto
se volete andare a vedere l'articolo è
il sito best movie link sono tutti e due
nelle informazioni grazie mille e spero
vi piaccia la nuova recensione
[Musica]
allora avete presente quando andate nei
centri commerciali quei grandi centri
commerciali che hanno il reparto
tecnologia film e musica mai andate in
quel reparto per cercare un film vedete
tutte le sezioni divise dai film a 5
euro e 99 euro e 90 14 anni 90 e così
via poi però c'è sempre quella chesta
maledetta con i film da
152 euro e 90 al massimo e io lo so lo
so che in tutte le ceste dell'universo
vedrete sempre questo film skeleton man
quanti di voi hanno avuto il coraggio di
comprarlo e guardarlo io non me lo
aspettavo che fosse così
aberrante ma non corriamo troppo allora
è un horror del 2004 diretto da johnnie
martin giorni martin che prima di fare
il regista faceva lo stuntman
ok prima d'iniziare la recensione però
vorrei consigliarvi un canale e il
canale dei the wood frigge due ragazzi
molto molto simpatici che ho avuto il
piacere di conoscere di conoscere di
persona ad un incontro di un po di tempo
fa sono veramente simpaticissimi il loro
canale pieno zeppo di video divertenti
quindi se volete farvi due risate
iscrivetevi da loro e ditegli che vi ho
mandato io il canale come al solito è
linkato nelle informazioni del video
detto questo iniziamo questa [__]
recensione e vediamo quali sono i cinque
punti per cui skeleton man è un aborto
numero 5 la trama
la trama è quattro soldati mandati in
una missione in una foresta a caso
scompaiono allora venne mandato un'altra
squadra per vedere cosa è accaduto a
questi soldati e si scopre che è
un'entità non umana fa stragi di tutti i
soldati
alla fine ne rimarrà uno che riuscirà a
uccidere questo mostro storia banale già
vista i miliardi di altri film horror ma
ci sono due cose che mi hanno abbastanza
dato fastidio numero uno è l'entità
malvagia
questo succede quando non hai fantasia
un sacchetto della spazzatura con un
teschio dentro non lo dico per dire è
veramente un sacchetto della spazzatura
con un teschio dentro la seconda cosa
che mi ha dato particolarmente fastidio
della trama è la storia di questo mostro
ma no più caldo non proprio la storia
del mostro ma come i protagonisti sono
venuti a sapere della storia del mostro
durante la ricerca in questa foresta in
cui non c'è assolutamente anima viva nel
raggio di chilometri
incontrano un vagabondo in mezzo al
nulla
un po forzato ma vediamo facciamo che
vediamo quante scene forzati ci vogliono
per arrivare alla forzatura generale del
raccontare la storia del mostro
vagabonda in mezzo a una foresta dove
non c'è assolutamente nessun rock prima
forzatura il vagabondo prima di chiedere
qualsiasi cosa i militari gli chiede dei
fagioli dei vecchi
abbastanza casuale seconda forzatura e
guarda caso i nostri eroi hanno con loro
un barattolo di fagioli
conveniente che fa forzatura come per
magia senza che i protagonisti gli
abbiano chiesto assolutamente nulla lui
inizia a raccontare una storia il
vecchio ciò
[Musica]
ha dimostrato a se stesso e agli altri
di saper distruggere dai coraggiosi
ragazzi
non glie l'ha chiesto nessuno quarta
forzatura e secondo voi di cosa parlerà
la storia ma è ovvio del sacchetto della
spazzatura con il teschio dentro che
culo è la prima persona che capita gli
racconta proprio la storia dell'uomo che
stanno inseguendo quinta forzatura
è già sento le vostre domande ma come
niente finale a sorpresa
numero 4 cliffhanger il protagonista è
unico sopravvissuto della strage del
teschio riesce in una maniera disperata
ad ucciderlo ma tanto lo sappiamo che la
sorpresa in agguato dai dai dai che
arriva eccola solo pronto dai dai ecco
ma eccola che arriva eccola
no magari volevano evitare il clichè del
finale a sorpresa come tutti i film di
serie b
[Musica]
[Applauso]
queste loro fino alla sorpresa il
riavvolgimento dei titoli di coda e poi
far vedere una scena casuali ma del
teschio a cavallo in mezzo alla foresta
è come se si fossero dimenticherò
neanche dimenticati come si fossero
accorti dopo di non aver messo un fine
alla sorpresa però c'è da dire una cosa
era un finale a sorpresa a sorpresa
perché non te l'aspetti sembra che sia
finito il film invece c'è ancora una
parte mi sa che hanno preso un po troppo
alla lettera questa cosa pessima nei jia
jia jia adriatica
numero 3 regia perché fin puoi
aspettarti da uno che prima facevano
stuntman allora partiamo dal budget è
stato stimato un budget di stato stimato
quindi non si sa per certo
2.3 milioni di dollari che non è poco
che avrebbero potuto benissimo dare in
beneficenza oppure dare indirettamente a
giorni martin per evitare di fare film
ma comunque la regia è abbastanza
basilare ma c'è qualcosa che non va in
alcune scene questi due milioni e mezzo
di dollari circa
credo che siano finiti tutti quanti in
esplosioni esplosioni sono grandi sono
infuocate sono belle per un b movie ma
guardate come sono state rese
cioè tu hai i soldi per fare
un'esplosione del genere anche bella e
appena parte la vera e propria
esplosione transizione su un'altra scena
all'improvviso ti vergognavi è una delle
poche cose decenti il film non me la fai
neanche vedere bene e come se non
bastasse ce ne sono altre due di
esplosioni inutili tuoi soldi per far
esplodere un elicottero di far cadere
precipitare esplodere un elicottero e
anche quello transizioni via così alla
veloce ma la cosa peggiore è una scena
di flashback del vietnam e di uno dei
protagonisti
che sembra quasi fatta bene ma dura due
secondi ed è piena di esplosioni che
sono completamente inutili perché fanno
parte 1 di un flashback e 2 che le fa
vedere mezzo secondo pessima
vabbè ormai avete capito
numero due erroracci e qui
inizia la discesa verso l'oblio partiamo
già subito con i primi due minuti di
film due in questi minuti c'è una
telefonata in cui però viene inquadrato
soltanto uno che telefono all'altro si
sente solo per voce ma sentite bene come
si sente
pronto charles buonasera dei michel hai
buone notizie per me siamo entrati nella
tomba nascosta abbiamo il cranio del
gran capo 6 orsi fantastico charlie i
nostri agenti saranno molto felice non
sono neanche riusciti a mettere un
effetto telefonico alla voce dall'altra
parte del telefono e non succede solo
qui succede ogni volta che qualcuno
utilizza una radio nel film però c'è da
dire che non so di chi sia il problema
se neanche il film originale era così
oppure sei colpa del doppiaggio italiano
che non ha messo gli effetti altro
errore
questo evitabilissimo in una scena uno
dei soldati a un mitragliatore con tipo
di mirino sopra se voi andate a vedere
bene bene bene la scena noterete che il
mirino è chiuso dio santo è chiuso ma
porca male anche a un bambino di 5 anni
e qui ti caldo sulla telecamere
riuscirebbe a fare un errore del genere
e come se non bastasse le l'inquadratura
subito dopo gli emiri o cambia ma se ma
chi se ne frega non ricordiamo le queste
scene tanto chi se lo guarda film
figurati poi
una cosa che non mi era mai capitata in
vita mia
in una scena in cui c'è il gruppo di
militari che trova per la seconda o
terza volta il sacco della spazzatura
con il teschio dentro cosa fa gli spara
ovviamente
sinti e dagli alberi
non so neanche cosa dire notate prima di
tutto la grandissima mira con quei
militari militari specializzati sparano
al nemico un colpo che neanche ci va da
vicino per terra tutti contro gli alberi
certo finché tv il mirino chiuso grazie
al cavolo ma poi con che esplodono i
confronti alberi in una miriade di fumo
e scintille come se fossero petardi mi
arrendo cioè cosa devo fare
cosa devo fà non voi non potete neanche
immaginare la miriade di errori che ci
sono di cui non posso parlare di tutto
perché se non rimarrei qua tutta la vita
per esempio ve lo dica la veloce ci sono
scene come al solito nei film di serie b
riutilizzate ma non so neanche quante
volte le scene d'azione soprattutto che
guarda caso sono tre quarti di film
riutilizzate fino allo svenimento
c'è anche nella parte finale della
battaglia finale non ha senso niente che
a un certo punto l'unico sopravvissuto
che va di agli operai
si la7 ok oggi la corrente così e con la
corrente
così è la scena senza corrente il signor
distante
corrente donna
non c'è nessuna differenza non hanno
staccato la corrente dovrebbe essere
tutto buio perché lui addirittura
accende la torcia cosa accendendo c'è
che esattamente come prima e tutto
acceso non è che me lo immagino e tutto
acceso
meno male che sono riuscito a finire la
sua presunzione di avere avesse
continuato come sparato un colpo in
testa e via
merda
1 perchè è tuffato e la pistola dove ok
ok la finisco in fretta guardate così
non ci penso più
un'ora e mezza di film
un'ora e mezza di tortura avete presente
hostel una puntata di ideal confronto ci
sono questi momenti in cui io mi
immaginavo lo sceneggiatore al lavoro
che doveva proprio scrivere queste scene
per filo e per segno di farah proprio
così il cerco di raccontarveli ma
sarebbe molto meglio vederle c'è vederle
durante il film perché raccontate perde
un po del loro
fascino anche se sarebbe meglio
chiamarlo vomito nella prima scena in
cui ci sono i due militari che vengono
sterminati dal teschio vengono
normalmente uccisi poi succede questo in
pratica il teschio vali per recuperare
un teschio praticamente i militari in
uno scavo hanno trovato un mezzo teschio
che tengono lì sullo scaffale e il
temine mico il sacco della spazzatura
per qualche ragione che sono sono
riuscito a capire lo vuole semplicissimo
noi cedono evitare che però muore
accasciato davanti allo scaffale in cui
c'è il teschio davvero butti giù tanto e
morte lo prendi
[Musica]
perché
perché mai avrebbe dovuto passare
attraverso con la mano per prendere il
teschio che era dietro di lui
non è neanche immaginando mio di di fare
io proprio io stesso il peggior film
della storia del cinema riesce né a chi
immagina nola vicini a me non va di lana
non lascerà il genere in un'altra scena
in cui il teschio ancora il protagonista
mentre sta lottando con i militari
riesce a colpirne uno
o salto a un po sporcato l'atterraggio
però 9.8 glielo do
ma perché provo chiederlo lentamente
qual è il motivo per cui un colpo
dovrebbe
rompere le leggi della fisica tra [__]
che ha fatto male c'è una scena brutta è
fatta male noi quando fa quel carpiato a
terra tipo con i piedi lui è già morto
ma a terra con i piedi e rimbalzando
quelle poi precipita al suolo cambiamo
scena in un'altra scena si vedono gli
ultimi due sopravvissuti che camminano e
camminano non c'è niente di sbagliato in
questa scena
[Musica]
stai bene
ok lasciate che me la spieghi mentre
stanno camminando lui inciampa su un
tronco e percepita per tipo 50 metri
ruzzolando come un pazzo rischiano di
rompersi l'osso del collo per trovare
dei cadaveri che con la trama non hanno
nulla a che fare ma pensateci bene quel
colpa dello sceneggiatore cerchi che
potrebbe mai immaginare la scena in cui
uno cade così come un sacco di patate
rischia la morte soltanto per nulla
perché è oltre il danno la beffa
verso la fine della sequenza si può
benissimo notare che il protagonista per
del cappello ma appena cade ce l'ha di
nuovo in testa questa scena è
imbattibile ma neanche drogati piantando
di due siringhe negli occhi il tuo
cervello riuscirebbe ad elaborare una
cosa del genere basta potete smettere di
guardare film questa è la scena la scena
con la s maiuscola dopo le scene dopo di
queste non potranno mai superarla in
bellezza impatti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
basta spesso
allora
lui in mezzo alla foresta più cupa trova
un'autostrada in questa autostrada
c'è un camion un autocisterna
lui ruba l'autocisterna ad un certo
punto appare il teschio in autostrada
lui accelera per schiacciarlo il teschio
scompare e lui invece di frenare o fare
qualcos'altro della natura umana nelle
reazioni umane si schianta contro
l'automobile lalalala la cisterna
esplode lui riesce a salvarsi
il testo compare vi compare dal nulla
per tagliargli le gambe
perché
wow
la zona del sapere allora esiste
ora finalmente ho aperto gli occhi sono
riuscito finalmente a comprendere la
scena della marotta verso il torace
e ovvio il regista aveva un litro e
mezzo di sangue in più poteva mica
andare sprecato geniale la scena del
doppio salto carpiato il regista aveva
scoperto che uno dei suoi attori era un
tuffatore professionista poteva mai
lasciarsi sfuggire un'occasione del
genere che stupido che sono stato a non
pensarci prima la scena di lui che
inciampa e ovvio che quello
sceneggiatore voleva far capire allo
spettatore che i pericoli non sono mai
finiti anche quando sei vicino alla fine
basta un piccolo ammetto è tutto cade
spettacolare e per finire la scena
dell'autocisterna a questa scena
racchiude tutta l'essenza del film lui
che fa di tutto per andare a fermare il
male ma alla fine perisce per questo ti
fa capire il coraggio e la ragione dei
protagonisti anche quando è tutto
inutile non ero riuscito a capirlo prima
ora ho aperto gli occhi
[Musica]
ok la recensione
è finita
il film vi consiglio di guardarlo perché
è qualcosa
altro è qualcos'altro
tutti i film sono in un modo lui è
veramente un mondo tutto suo e di
consiglio di guardano con gli amici
perché così mi salvano la vita in caso
voleste
suicidarvi quindi ne approfitto però per
questa fine di accensione per
ringraziarvi di nuovo di cuore di tutti
gli iscritti ormai siete oltre 40.000 io
sono contentissimo vedo che vi piacciono
molto vi piacciono i miei video io sono
veramente contentissimo io mi diverto
sacco a farli i vostri messaggi si
quadruplicano su facebook cerco di
rispondere molto di più che su youtube
perché su youtube mi dà proprio fastidio
ci metta cari 2 ora carica se devo
scrivere due al devo rispondere a due
persone su facebook ci metto due secondi
su youtube ci metto mezz'ora e quindi su
youtube su facebook risponde più in
fretta e poi ripeto volevo fare qualcosa
non lo fare un mini micro concorsino ma
proprio mini micro
non niente di ufficiale non so ancora se
lo farò però non sarà sui video perché
siete tantissimi e sareste impossibili
da non da vedere tutti da vedere
riuscire a vedere ma da giudicare perché
siete talmente tanti talmente diversi
nel fare le cose che sarebbe impossibile
però voglio ringraziarli e io volevo
fare un concorso per cambiarmi la
grafica mi piacerebbe cambiarla che a
kakà fissa ha fatto un ottimo lavoro
però mi piacerebbe aggiornarne ogni
tanto mi a me dopo un po mi annoiano
vedere la stessa grafica e volevo
cambiarla
lei le cose sono tre sfondo banner del
canale bannerino sopra i video
poi vabbè adesso niente di ufficiale
ripeto poi vi darò tutte le misure se se
lo farò per il premio sarà un film un
premio vero fisico un film squallido ma
bellissimo quindi su good quasi che ho
visto e mi piace molto male che non ho
che non ho che ho visto il negozio c'è
quindi ne prendono due copie ora per me
e ora per voi per chi vincerà sarà tutta
una scelta personale ovviamente perché
quello è c'è la grafica deve piacermi
quindi sarà tutto su personale
ve lo dirò poi comunque non sono ancora
sicuro di farlo ma al 90 per cento si
quindi io vi ringrazio tantissimo di
tutti i commenti di tutti i complimenti
e ci vediamo alla prossima recensione